you really can't believe it until you
actually go there you can't believe it
until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome I want to show you one more uh
throwback I think we've shown this to
you once or twice of Elon talking about
why he bought Twitter in the first place
and do you think that maybe this is
connected to everything that we're
talking about today what was it
ultimately that led you to make the
decision to do
it I mean this is going to sound uh
somewhat melodramatic but I was worried
about that that it was having a
corrosive effect on
civilization uh that I was uh just
having a bad a bad impact um and
um I think part of it is that it's where
it's where it was located which is uh
you know downtown San Francisco um and
while I I think San Francisco is a
beautiful city and and we should really
fight hard to
um kind of write the ship of San
Francisco if you've walked around
downtown San Francisco right near the
xfk Twitter headquarters it's a zombie
apocalypse I mean it's rough have you
have you been been in that area not
lately no I've heard it's crazy I've
heard it's crazy I've heard you you
really can't believe it until you
actually go there you can't believe it
until you go there so now you have to
say well what philosophy led to that
outcome and that philosophy was being
piped to Earth
so um you know a philosophy that would
be ordinarily quite Niche and
geographically constrained so the that
sort of the fallout area would be
limited um was effectively given an
information a
weapon um a tech Information Technology
weapon to
propagate uh what is essentially a mind
virus to the rest of both um and the
outcome of that mind virus is very clear
if you walk around the streets of
downtown San Francisco it is the end of
civilization that's Elon at his best
right like listen to how calmly and
cleanly he is explaining what's going on
there and how he's connecting what he
was seeing on the Streets of San
Francisco and I can vouch for that
personally because I stood up in his
corner office up there with the windows
going both ways with Elon looking down
and he was talking about where they get
the drugs where they do the drugs that's
where they're all beaten the crap out of
each other and all of that stuff but
what he's saying is that this Niche
ideology meaning the collectivist
ideology what we now all know as as
wokeism which is really just
collectivism with a dash of racism and a
dash of gender confusion and all of that
it was it's a niche ideology that would
have been left in certain Geographic
places throughout time right like there
would have been little pockets of it
here and there but it was weaponized by
big Tech and then the government and
then through algorithmic tricks it was
pushed everywhere which leads us to
exactly where we are at the
moment